hi everyone this is jeremy shifling from
khan academy
thanks so much for taking time to join
me in this big week either before the
start of school
or in the middle of the start of school
depending on where you're calling from
but wherever you are in your own
educational journey this school year
i'm really excited that you joined us
for our student experience demo
this is all about a chance to basically
go behind the curtain
and see what your students see on khan
academy so you can make the most of this
tool this year that being said
just a couple of things to get started
here i want to call out as
always that like every khan academy
webinar we will be recording the session
and then sharing it in your email in
about an hour so it'll happen
automatically
whether you can join for the whole
session or whether you have to run out
and make dinner or anything else so
have no fear you will have that in your
inbox shortly in the meantime you can
even get the slides themselves
through the handout section right now on
the go to webinar control panel
so if you're really eager like me to see
where we're headed feel free to grab
that pdf under the handout section
and then finally because just like last
week's session i want to make this as
interactive as possible
please please please make sure that
you're logged into your khan academy
account that way you can follow along
and actually experience everything
just the same way that your students do
it'll make it a really fun session
and a really powerful one as well that
being said
i want to sort of cut to the chase here
and talk about
um one of our our big philosophies here
at khan academy which is that great
teaching
involves great empathy and i love this
quote from anne lieberman
which is that great teachers don't just
teach kids and lecture to kids they
empathize with kids they respect them
they understand where they're coming
from
and they serve those needs through that
empathy and i think to put it in a more
sort of
practical standpoint or a practical
perspective what i've heard from a lot
of educators
is i never really got khan academy until
i tried using it as a student
either for my own courses in college or
my own teacher test prep
or just trying to understand what my
students were saying that was the light
bulb moment
that's when i got it and so please put
yourself into your student's shoes for
the next
25 minutes or so and sort of experience
what your students experience
so that way you can give them the best
possible um experience this fall
okay to get things started we're going
to begin
with you joining my classroom on khan
academy the same way that students might
sign up for your own classroom
so again if you're already logged into
khan academy
all you want to do is go to bitly
con invite so i'm going to actually show
you what that looks like over here
so check this out so here i have you
know my teacher account set up
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
come over here to bitly
con invite i'm also going to put that in
the chat just so you can click the link
for even easier access and once you're
over there
what you will see is this little
invitation pop-up
and it's going to say hey you're joining
the student experience demo
are you ready to sort of plug into this
classroom
and i know it might seem a little
strange like what is this classroom that
jeremy has set up
but just roll with me a little bit here
go ahead and click
join student experience demo and you
will now be a registered member of our
sample class
and i will give you two minutes to do
the same on your side
i wish i wish i wish i could play some
jeopardy music right now
but at the very least um just follow the
invites on the screen
bitly con invite join my class
and if you have any questions whatsoever
feel free to ask them using the
questions section
of the go to webinar control panel i'm
happy to answer those live and over text
as we go along so again join my class
and that'll be the first step
towards seeing what your students see
looks like no questions coming in yet
which is awesome um
definitely probably not going to be
identical to the experience your
students have
mine always ask questions about
everything but
hopefully that means everyone is making
good progress and joining my class
and what you'll be able to see as a
teacher whether you're doing this over
zoom or doing this
in person is you'll be able to see
students coming into your class
in real time so check this out i'm going
to come over to my roster
this is the student experience demo i'm
going to click refresh
and what you're going to see now is that
all the teachers across the country who
are involved in this webinar
they have just joined this class which
is pretty incredible
um so sure enough they're coming in ali
is here alyssa's here christine's here
diane's here
thank you all so much and what i'm going
to do is actually include you in an
assignment shortly
but i will get back to that in a moment
i want to answer a couple questions
because folks are asking
um but leila says it looks like i'm
still my teacher's account absolutely
what you might have noticed in my demo
window here is that after you join my
class
khan always kicks you back to your
teacher homepage and that kind of keeps
you centered on the teacher experience
but have no fear i'm going to show you
where to actually confirm
that you are now a member of my class as
a learner great question delela
diane had the same question great point
melissa said the same so
sorry i didn't call that out my
apologies but yeah you will come back to
your teacher dashboard
but have no fear you are now registered
my class and it's showing up on the
screen right here so
i think at this point um everyone's had
a chance to join we have about
30 students from across the country
which is awesome so thank you all for
joining
um what i want to do now is do a couple
things for you
so first of all just sort of give you a
sense of how you might do this on your
own side
i'm going to make my screen a little
larger so it's easier to see and
if you ever want to share your own class
code with your students
all you have to do is come into your
classroom khan academy
come over to the students tab right down
here under admin
and then there's a nice share class code
link right in the upper right hand
corner
by clicking here i can grab the code
just like the one i gave you
now i put it behind a fancy little
bookmark from bitly
but you can share this link or whatever
form you want with your students and
they can join the exact same way you did
you can even print these instructions if
you want to share them in a different
way
or different languages but this is the
easiest way to get your students started
so there's your class code there's your
link then like i said
you can see your students coming in in
real time which is awesome
and now that you have your students here
and you're saying okay this all looks
really good
ally's here ellen's here diane's here
let me actually get you off to the races
with an assignment
so i'm going to come over to the assign
section what i'm going to do is just
walk you through what the teacher is
saying
now that her students or his students
are enrolled so i come down here
i say you know what i'm going to start
you off um
maybe in this case you know what i'm
going to switch things up i'm going to
start you off with a grammar
lesson because i got some free feedback
in my last webinar
jeremy i love all the stuff you're doing
but it's too much math math math
let's shake it up a little bit you're
absolutely right so let's do a grammar
lesson right now
and let's focus on identifying nouns so
i come over to a sign
i click this little check box i click
assign one
i'm going to say all of my students in
my class are going to get this
assignment
so here we go all students
you have till tomorrow we're going to do
right now i'm going to have you all do
the same question set so we can review
together as a class which is pretty
powerful over video conference
i'm going to assign that right now and
so
if we switch back into our student
experience
you've gone from enrolling in my class
to now having a chance to actually get
information and assignments as a student
now to get there what i want you to do
is to switch from your teacher view kind
of the teacher hat that you're wearing
into student mode and see your student
view and the way you're going to do that
and i'll walk you through it right here
on my screen
is you're going to come over here you're
going to
come up to your name in the upper right
hand corner i'm going to actually shrink
it a little bit so you can see that
so i have salvador you might be diane
you might be eileen
whatever it is you're going to click
right in the upper right hand corner and
then you're going to click
learner home and basically what this is
telling khan academy
is hey i'm about to switch identities
i'm a teacher and a learner
and in this case i want to focus on the
learner view so learn your home is where
you want to go
and if you've actually done it what you
should now see
is under the student experience demo
you will see this assignment that i've
just given which is identifying nouns
and just to sort of reiterate as i have
here in this teacher note
if you click your name one more time
you'll notice that there's
there are these notifications that are
letting you know that you've just
received this assignment
so if you click the notification link
you can see that the assignment has come
in
this is one way that you can communicate
with students obviously you can let them
know about assignments
verbally during a zoom session via
remind via class dojo
via google classroom all sorts of
different ways but fundamentally every
time you make an assignment
it'll pop up in the notification section
and so now
to move on to the last section um i want
to give you a chance to get into your
student view
so if you haven't done this already take
one minute right now
and click your name and then click into
learner home
and your time starts now i've always
wanted to say that would want to be a
game show host
come on into your student view again
you're coming over to your name
and you're clicking learn or home and
that'll take you right there
just as we make sure everyone's on the
same page before we move forward i'm
going to answer some questions
um regina did get a little prompt that
said i was not able to get into the
session
it asked me to create an account or log
into my existing account
that's totally fine if you don't want to
use your existing teacher account
you can always create a new student
account maybe with your personal gmail
for instance
for the purposes of this session totally
fine to keep it separate
great question regina okay about 15
seconds left
you want to make sure that everyone is
now in the learner home
where you're going to see your
assignments you're going to see all the
interaction with the teacher in this
case
and once the timer is up we'll move on
to the next section
thank you all for being rockstar
students i can tell this class is going
to go far
okay time's up let's move on to the
third step
and that is a chance to actually do the
assignment and i know this might seem a
little funny to actually be doing the
work on count academy as opposed to
assigning the work
but again i think it's so important to
really see that fundamental thing that
your students experience
of what does an assignment look like how
does it feel how do i get help when i'm
stuck
and so what i would love for you to do
is do exactly what i'm going to show you
on my screen right now
which is i come over here to my
assignment section i say aha my teacher
has made this assignment identify nouns
i scroll over i click the start button
and i'm literally just going to go
through this and try to answer these to
the best of my abilities
um so now not a noun not a noun noun
check get that nice little reward remind
the next question
and what i'll challenge you to do as you
go through this is to actually try
getting it wrong once in a while or
asking for a hint
just to see what that experience looks
like you know especially with all these
students learning over distance right
now
they may not always be able to reach you
with questions
so in that case how can you instruct
them on how to use the hint system and
the video system
well first of all try it out yourself
and then you'll be empowered to really
support them
going forward it's been about five
minutes going through it right now
i'll start the timer and again
just to sort of retrace my steps i'm in
my learner home
i'm going to my assignment section i'm
clicking start
and i'm just literally going through
this as a student would one question
after another
getting stuck sometimes getting hints
and getting a sense of how this all
feels and how it all works
because once you understand that you can
really translate it for your students
so as you do that again feel free to ask
any questions via the questions feature
and go to webinar
i'll be happy to answer those live um
balayla says should we watch the video
also totally up to you
layla if you're one of those superstar
students of zooming ahead
and you have time to not only do the
exercise or watch the video go for it
get a sense of what those con videos
feel like great question
um christina's saying i can get to the
learner home
but i can't see the assignment so i just
want to call this out
you may have multiple courses here
depending on how many things you've
signed up for as a learner
definitely make sure that you come over
to the student experience demo
which is the name of my particular
course good question christine
um and melissa says will this link still
be active
so we can show the kids the student view
demo absolutely i'm going to leave this
classroom up for the entire academic
year
so if you ever want to log back in and
sort of reconnect with this experience
or share with your own students
by all means and also know that you can
certainly do the same on your own end
you can always create a sample classroom
you can add yourself to it
and really see what students are seeing
or make it easy for your students to
play around in kind of a sandbox
environment if you will
so definitely feel free to take
advantage of all these resources both
now and in the future
thanks for asking that melissa
okay we're about halfway through so
hopefully you're having fun
um getting in touch with those old
school grammar mechanics
i know it's probably been a while unless
you do teach grammar yourself but
um definitely fun to see what our
students see and see the structure
that's built in as far as
those rewards we teach when students are
getting it right and also the support
structure that's in place
when they need a little extra help
so sherry says my school is not listed
and what she's referring to is a school
picker
um that appears at the very top of the
khan academy dashboard
let me show you what that looks like so
here i am logged in as a teacher again
it says add your school and you may
search in your zip code and you may not
find your school
absolutely no worries you can still use
it 100
we are working really hard to get
additional schools added to this
so if you see any trouble with sherry
please send us a
request after this webinar and we'll try
to get that school added
i'm going to show you how to make that
request in about 10 minutes so thanks
for calling that out
um let's see here
sherry is asking if i am tutoring should
this process work
absolutely whether you're working with
five students or 150 students
everything i'm showing you is exactly
the same and so whether it's
choosing content for your students or
your tutees
making assignments everything can be
done no matter how many students you
have
thanks for asking sherry
let's see here tamera is saying is there
a way to have my student access to
practice questions that i located by
doing a search on the topic
ideals of democracy i haven't seen a way
to find them from the student page
yeah so such a good question one of
those sort of powerful hidden things in
khan academy
is that you can come in here and you can
search for whatever you want so ideals
of democracy voila
here's the awesome thing that tamera
found
you can definitely you know go into your
um
your teach your classroom and
add that as a class that you want to use
and go through the full assignment
process like i demoed
you know about five minutes ago but what
you can actually do
is from this page you can start to
assign it so check this out
here's us a sign bar at the very top and
if we make this a little bit bigger
i'm just going to blow this up on your
screen i can say aha it deals with
democracy this is the perfect piece of
practice i'm going to assign it to my
class
to these students i can give them the
same questions or different questions
and i can give them a clear deadline and
that way without even going into the
assignment mode
you can assign something the minute you
find it so a really powerful way to
immediately get that practice into your
students hands
hopefully that's helpful big question
tamara
all right about 10 seconds left um
lisa is asking what would be a valuable
way to use khan academy for virtual
learning
lisa i would highly recommend that you
check out last week's webinar
which is on our youtube playlist and
i'll share a link later
which gets into all the stuff around you
know using khan academy during a zoom
session
before zoom session after zoom session
but then the bottom line is
you don't want to have too much lecture
in that rare moment of
teacher student interaction instead you
want to make it really engaging like sao
khan talked about in his new york times
op-ed a couple weeks ago
and so try to use khan academy to
offload some of that stuff
have the students watch the video ahead
of time have them do some practice ahead
of time
and that way you can use those virtual
sessions for lots of engagement where
you
make cold calls you ask questions you
give pop quizzes and get students
thinking in real time
that's my advice okay let me pause on
the questions for a second and i'll come
back to the promise
in the interest of time i want to now
actually switch from student mode into
teacher mode
so you can see the fruits of your labor
so everyone's done the assignment
and by the way here's one really cool
thing that's unique to the fall at khan
academy
is as you probably heard we have this
cool program called learnstorm
which is like everything on khan academy
a free program
to motivate your students to really be
their best especially at this very tough
moment
and to help celebrate as a class your
progress together
you can always come to your learn storm
tracker so check this out
so your learns from tracker is always
going to be found at the top
of your khan academy dashboard so here i
am as a teacher i'm logged in
and sure enough the very first thing is
check my progress
how am i doing on learnstorm you can
literally show this
to your students to get them so pumped
up
so you come over here to student
experience demo which is the name of our
class
i check for progress and check this out
watch
this climb so fast as a tribute to all
the hard work you just did
so if you ever need a little extra way
to bring oomph and excitement
um to the back to school season this is
the way to say hey we are all in this
thing together
and even though we may be a part of this
moment we are working together to do big
things
you can track the progress with this
learn storm tool and share that with
your class during a zoom session
just by sharing your screen so
definitely check that out it's pretty
fun
okay now back to the flow so you've done
this assignment as a student
what would you do with that information
as a teacher let's review this together
so i'm going to come back to my class
again it's called student experience
demo
and this time instead of going to a sign
i'm going to go to scores
let me actually make this a little bit
bigger so it's a little easier to see
and so i'm going to refresh this
and i'm going to check out the results
from all of your hard work on this
assignment
um so sorry to put everyone on the spot
here but i do want to showcase
some of the great stuff you all have
done so go over to identifying nouns
which is the exercise you just did
and voila check this out i love this so
much because it's kind of like x-ray
vision for teachers
where you can drill down to the question
level and figure out how things are
going
and so one of the things that i
immediately see is that question one
you all are nailing 26 out of 29 of you
got that on the very first try
fantastic whereas question 4 was maybe
more of a struggle
so i want to drill down to that question
and i say aha
i see that six students got the
incorrect answer
so maybe i reteach this one and i go
over things like
is a preposition a noun is something
like a
exciting adjective like creepy a noun
and i use it for there as a teaching
moment to say
i know a lot of us are sort of running
into trouble here
but let's solve it together let's come
together as a class to address those
misconceptions and make sure that we're
all on the same page moving forward
and again you can definitely on your own
time click in and see the exact students
who are correct or incorrect
but for now khan keeps it all anonymous
which is nice for you
because you can show your students that
you're paying attention to their work
and they're looking at it as a class
together without calling out any one
student
so it's just a nice way to bring the
class together around your shared work
and your shared experience
so i highly recommend going into these
assignment scores
to give that kind of report out to your
class okay
so we're back to our flow now um what
we've talked about so far is getting
started as a student
going into your learner home doing your
first assignment
but if you followed any of the things
that sal khan's been talking about these
last couple years
even pre-covid you know that assignments
are just the tip of the iceberg
one of the things that we strongly
believe in at khan academy is the power
of course
mastery to really help students do their
best especially in this difficult moment
and that's the idea rather than just
move together a lockstep and say hey
you know half our classes maybe not
getting it right but that's okay we've
got to move forward
let's have each student continue to work
on that skill until they reach mastery
so when they move on to the next skill
and the next unit they don't have those
swiss cheese gaps in their foundations
and they move forward stronger and more
confident than ever before
so if you want to take advantage of
course mastery check this out
i'm going to come back into my teacher
dashboard just to show you what this
looks like
i come into the course mastery section
over here so not assignments
i click placement i'm going to set a
goal
so check this out i'm going to say i
want to create a goal
for the 40 new students in my class and
i'm going to say
instead of focusing on grammar let's
move to second grade math
and i want you to master this topic by
let's say the end of the school year so
june 1st give or take
so we create that goal and now
what's going to happen on your end is
back in your learner home
you're going to start to see that filter
in
to your course mastery section so to
show you what that looks like
we're going to switch back into our
learner view so
as you may recall we click our name in
the upper right hand corner we click
learner home and this time voila
a new section has appeared before we had
assignments and we did the assignment
that was great
but now there's course mastery and to
dig into course mastery
here's exactly what you do you can
follow along on your own screen
so first of all you click second grade
that's the goal for the year i want you
to master
this body of content all the related
skills
i click into that now if you are perhaps
a third grade teacher
and you want to make sure that your
students master second grade before
moving on
you can have them start with a course
challenge that's a quick way to recap
how they're doing at the start but for
our purposes let's say no thanks
and let's just follow the blue buttons
because really that's kind of the
digital cookie crumb trail
that you want to teach your students to
always follow when in doubt
look for the blue so in this case we go
to get started under the first unit
then we go for the first blue button
which is the first scale of second grade
math
adding within 20 visually again we click
the start button
and did we dive right into this practice
session let's go
so just like before i would love for you
to spend a few minutes
doing your first experience of course
mastery as a student
so you can see what that feels like so
i'm going to start the timer over here
and again just to retrace my steps
um i was back here on my teacher
dashboard and i came to my name
i came to learner home um
and then i found out that i had not just
assignments but also course mastery
i'm going to refresh that voila there's
course mastery
i click second grade to dig into this
lofty goal we have
say no thanks to course challenge for
now and then i just follow the
blue buttons get started and start the
skill
and now i'm off to the races so again
spend a few minutes just going through
that
try getting a couple of answers right a
couple wrong
see how khan academy responds and how it
supports you along the way
and as you do that i'm going to answer
some questions that have come in
so let's see here
diane says do you have a suggestion for
how to pick just one assignment for a
particular topic
when i assigned a topic to a student
they signed a large number of
assignments and became totally
unmanageable which overwhelmed the
student
and i feel your pain diane because this
is one of the biggest pitfalls that i
encountered
when i first started using khan academy
is i would be over here
on my teacher screen and i would say
you know what i'm going to do an
assignment i'm going to assign
basically an entire unit well the
problem with that
is that i'm assigning 24 things at once
that's videos maybe articles some
practice
that's way too much i highly recommend
being laser focused
especially at the start of the year
you're just getting your students warmed
up
and you say there's only one thing i
want you to focus on and most likely
that's the thing that you just talked
about in class
during your last session so if i had
just taught about adding and subtracting
within 20
i would choose only that singular skill
and i would assign only that
and that way we have baby steps in the
khan academy as opposed to that feeling
of being overwhelmed
great question i am okay juliette is
saying
how do you assign something on google
classroom so the first thing is
you do have to assign it using the
techniques we've already talked about on
khan academy
if you want to be able to track it on
khan academy and get all those valuable
reports
so that means either assigning it
through your teacher dashboard or
actually on the section itself using
that little assigned blue bar
but that being said once you have
something going
here's what you can do next um let me
actually
just get this going for you here hold on
one moment
so if we expand this
and we get out of this modal mode
you'll notice there's this google
classroom link under every video and
every practice
and by clicking that link just like you
would a facebook link or a twitter link
you're basically sending it to your
google classroom so as long as you're
logged into google as long as your
classroom is set up
you can specifically send that piece of
content straight into your classroom
account
and that's a nice supplement to the
assignments that already exist in khan
academy
hope that helps okay let's keep tabs on
our timer here we're down to about two
minutes um
okay great question juliet because
tamara is doing well lisa's doing well
um let's see here ooh yesenia says
how do we archive last year's class in
order to start a new class this year
great question so if you have something
that you want to get rid of because it's
cluttering up your teacher dashboard
you can always come down to the settings
and just say you know what
i'm going to delete this class and the
data still exists
so the teacher the students aren't going
to lose their data um but it will be
removed from your dashboard
so you don't have all this information
overwhelming you because overwhelm is
real not just for students but also for
educators
so definitely check that out yesenia all
right let's see here
and then melissa said how do you get to
that gradebook again so if you ever want
to get back to that assignment gradebook
all you do is assignments and then
scores
and voila you now have the results for
each of those sections so identify nouns
let's see how students did okay so now
we're down to the final 30 seconds um
rosemary is saying do students um do
work with pen and paper at desk or can
they sell digitally
oh such a good question i'm glad you
brought that up rosemary so
when you are doing work on khan academy
you may have noticed this and i hope
this is one of the benefits of actually
doing these things is that you can
actually start to draw
on the screen as a student so whether
you're using your computer or chromebook
or tablet or phone you click this little
button
and you can literally do some doodles
and some sort of quick calculations
right on your screen but what i always
encourage students to do
is whatever is most effective for them
if that means using pen and paper if
that means using a little sort of
personal whiteboard on their desk by all
means
great question all right
so we have come to the end of step five
and now this is the big moment of truth
so don't fail me now is our final step
reviewing the progress together and i'm
super excited to see
to show you not just course master
progress at a high level
but specifically x-ray view into the
skills that your students are generating
so again everyone in my class has just
completed their first course mastery
practice
which is awesome when i come here i can
look at that through two different
lenses
first of all i have this lens of overall
course progress
and i can say melissa and pamela and
regina are off to the races they're
doing great
and i can literally track that at the
unit level and at the overall course
level as well because
your goal is always 100 course mastery i
want everyone in my class to master all
these skills
however just this summer have we rolled
out a brand new report called
skills and here's where you find it so
again you're in your teacher dashboard
you're in your specific classroom and
you go to activity overview
and then you go to skills and what you
will find here
are all the skills in your entire course
whether it's grammar whether it's math
whether it's science
all laid out for you and then when you
click on it
you can actually see how everyone is
doing in terms of that spectrum
from first getting started getting
familiar to getting proficient and
ultimately mastering that skill
i think this is such a powerful thing
because you know when i was a teacher
i almost did all of my assessment at the
unit level and i knew who was succeeding
in general
and who was struggling in general but i
didn't always know
the specific students and the specific
skills that were holding them back
and now you have that all in a single
report so what you might say
is okay i'm feeling great about larry
and ori and miss daniel
but i'm a little worried about tammy and
kristen
and what you can do is you can actually
assign the skill just to the students
who might be struggling a little bit
and that way they get that extra
practice before you move on as a class
so again put on those x-ray goggles get
a sense of how your class is doing
and this is a really powerful new report
that i hope i hope you'll try out
okay so now i know we're almost at time
so i do want to finish with a quick
recap for you
if there are three things that you want
to show your students at the start of
this year
whether your school year has already
begun or whether it's about to begin
next week
is number one when in doubt with
registration
the simplest thing to do is just share
your class link
you come into your class you come to
students
and you share that class code and
that'll get students up and running
pretty quickly number two
you're going to train your students that
once they've gone ahead and registered
all the action is going to appear on
their learner home
so they're going to come up to their
names they're going to click learner
home
and they're going to see all the classes
they're a part of and all their
assignments and all their course mastery
all in one place
and then finally as mentioned here in
the third point
assignments course mastery they'll be
notified right here
on their learner home so here are the
notifications here's what's coming in
here's what's due and that way even if
everyone is learning at home learning
remotely you can centralize that the
single source of truth about what you're
handing out
all in one place that being said
a couple things i want to call out
before i start taking your questions
live again
i know they're going to be more
questions either now or in the next few
weeks
so i want you to have all the resources
possible number one i want to try to
take as many questions as possible right
now
but if you don't get your question
answered or if something else comes up
over the long weekend or in the showers
or getting ready for the first day of
school
here are two amazing resources number
one
you can always ask our support team
using this link bitly slash con question
basically what that is doing is it's
taking you
from the the help link at the very top
so click your name
you click help and then you report a
problem
even though that sounds kind of negative
it's basically a chance to say hey
i've got an idea for khan academy or i
have a bug in khan academy or i have a
question about khan academy
and we typically respond a couple of
hours even at the start of the school
year so definitely
lean on our community support team for
help and then in addition
make sure to check out with fellow
teachers what they're doing and learn
from their best practices
and you can do that on our facebook
group called teachwithcon
and as you can see people are saying
help i have a question and teachers are
sort of coming in and
sort of sharing their expertise left
right and central so take advantage of
that tool
as the school year dawns okay that being
said
let me take your questions live now so
um stephanie i'm going to lead off with
you you say our students have fake
google email addresses
khan academy recognizes them but it's
going to work in the same way to log in
absolutely even if you've totally made
up these google accounts
just for the purposes of getting your
students enrolled everything is the same
they come in they log in with those fake
credentials that you created for them
and they're going to see that same
learner home those same assignments that
same court
same course mastery goals regardless of
how they log in
so definitely you're gonna see very
similar results
um let's see here um
melissa says is the drawing tool
available for english
yeah great question so let's actually
try that out together so we're going to
come back to khan academy
we're going to come back to our student
experience demo
and we're going to go back into that
sort of grade book if you will identify
nouns
and what i'm happy to say is that voila
hears this virtual whiteboard even for a
grammar
so if you want to do any sentence
diagrams if you want to break out your
digital red pen
by all means go ahead and take uh take
advantage of this tool
because it is a nice way even if you
don't have a whiteboard built in like
zoom has and you're using a different
platform
you can absolutely start drawing right
here and get your students off to the
races
great question melissa um holly says how
can i unassign something oh
i signed too much not knowing what i was
doing and i totally get it holly
i was in that same boat when i was
playing around with khan academy at
first
but what you want to do is you want to
come back here to the assignment section
you want to say manage this time so
that's the last of these three options
and then you want to come in here and
say you know what i went a little bit
overboard
let me go ahead and edit this assignment
in this case
you know maybe i'll go ahead and delete
it um in that case
you don't have to have all these
students suffering under all these
assignments
you can keep it way more simple hope
that helps okay great question
um let's see um stephanie says i am an
instructional math coach with no kids of
my own to experiment on thanks jeremy
okay
absolutely i have to tell you all in
addition to being a former teacher
i have two little kids at home and they
are my khan academy guinea pig so they
are so sick of all this stuff but
i have tried it out on them definitely
kid tested
if not get approved okay um rosemary
says
can i sign mastery in small chunks with
a short deadline
for example i want to see how a new
fourth grader understands
great place value yeah so i actually
have a really cool new resource for you
rosemary
right now it is sort of a mid-flaw of
course mastery
which is that it operates at this course
level which can often feel
too massive especially at the start of
the year but brand new on khan academy
this year
is the ability to come in click courses
and then see these things called get
ready courses and what that is
is our attempt to get your students up
to speed for grade level
given that so much was up on the air
this past spring and so you're gonna
find
very curated sort of cuts of just the
most important skills for third grade
or for algebra or for pre-calculus and
so you can assign course mastery for
these courses
and that can be done in a couple weeks
not in 26 weeks
and hopefully that'll get you moving a
little bit faster hope that helps
rosemary
all right stephanie says wahoo wahoo
indeed um
diane says uh she's excited to be
joining thank you for being here diane
thank you for being such an awesome
student
um tamara says um
can you please explain a bit about
leveling up or down oh such a good
question
i'm taking the government class and i
went through a practice set today
i scored maybe like three out of four or
four out of five or something
it was the first time i had taken it and
then i was surprised to see the red air
the red down arrow
what's going on well it's so funny you
mentioned tamara
because sal khan was actually on this
radio show this morning i was listening
to
and a parent called in with the same
exact question which is like how
demoralizing is it for my kid
if all of a sudden i see the scores
going down
well the reason that that happens is
that what khan is trying to do
is trying to always assess the mastery
level of your students
and it wants to be pretty clear-eyed
about this it doesn't want to say hey
you know you mastered something in the
past but when we gave you some space
repetition when we showed it to you
again
and this time you totally didn't get it
well we can't really still call you at
sort of that mastered level
and so when in doubt i highly recommend
coming back to your um your uh
skills report so here's activity
overview
here's skills and check this out for
every single level
we will give you the definition of what
attempted familiar proficient and master
means
so if you're ever wondering why did i go
from master to proficient or familiar to
permanent christian
we will give you that intel that
definition right here so hopefully
that'll be the
rosetta stone if you will to explain
some of those
conundrums great question tamara
all right let's see here um well diane
says
how is get ready for fourth grade
different than using learnstorm
i'm so glad you asked this because
learnstorm
is more a sort of key motivational thing
that runs across
all the courses we offer so you may
notice at the top of khan academy in
this course directory
we kind of have this there's a massive
spectrum of content offerings
everything from math to stem to arts and
humanity even career courses
and so what we say is no matter what you
teach
we want to make sure that you get credit
for getting your students going
and your students get motivation
especially in this tough moment
and so anytime you make an assignment
and your students make progress
you will start to see that learn storm
tracker grow and that's true for
get ready courses it's true for ap art
history is true for everything
that said these get ready courses were
built specifically this year
given the fact that so many teachers
said i'm a little bit worried about the
fall
you know my own class in the spring
didn't end the way it would normally
we didn't cover all the content we would
normally get to so i can expect that
some of my students coming in
may be a little bit less prepared or a
little bit less unready than they would
have been in a normal year
and so this is specifically about
plugging those holes catching them up on
those key skills
so that in the middle of the year you
don't run into those swiss cheese gaps
that might be holding your student back
um and again if you assign some of this
work
it will also count towards learnstorm
but it is a little more focused on
content
than motivation because learnstorm is
about motivation at the end of the day
great question diane okay so let me sort
of come
come back here and give you a quick
recap um i love that you all
totally rocked my class today it makes
me feel really good as a teacher
to see that so many folks were getting
proficient in mastery on all those key
skills
what's more important to me quite
honestly is that you are ready to rock
your own classrooms this fall
if there's anything we can do to support
you along the way please let us know
ask questions to our support team
connect with us online
or even let me know in the survey after
the session what you want to see next
i have a team of a bunch of ambassadors
around the country
who are just chomping at the bit to
share their expertise with you in
response to your needs
so if you let me know that you need a
webinar about motivation or you need a
tool focused on xyz content
we will get to work on that in the
meantime i wish you all an amazing and
well deserved long weekend this weekend
and then a great start or resumption of
the year next week
i know there's a lot resting on your
shoulders but i also know you're going
to knock out of the park
thank you so much for all that you do
and here's wishing you tremendous
success
cheers everyone